and why is the target whole like
carrying the album Target their [__]
Communists and they hate black people
what happened with that yo every I tried
to go by action Bronson's album at
Target yeah he's on Atlantic they didn't
have of course because action Bronson's
black they hate blacks and they're
[__] Communists and they support
terrorism so [__] Target so [__] Target
um
uh uh Best Buy though you can go get it
at Best Buy Best Buy are low-key
Communists but they're starting to open
up because it I saw like a lot of fans
were saying that they were in the back
album was supposed to come out the 28th
of April
we got witches in three days that word
that oh [__] the album's been shipped so
I'm like okay I'm telling my fans hey
because my fans love buying physicals so
I'm like hey go and get the physical at
these stores but
it was only like four Best Buys that
decided to put it out out the whole
country right so it's a lot of fans
who's like hey do you have this CD
and the people that work at Best Buy if
it's not under new releases we don't
have it but my fans are persistent and
don't take no for an answer they're like
yo go to the back and check so they go
in the back and bring out one copy
instead of putting all of them out with
all the artwork and all that yeah with
everything but but I mean on the on the
28th it'll be I mean hopefully it'll be
hopefully it'll be everywhere I probably
[__] up ever being at Target because
they're [__] communist and
um
hopefully Best Buy likes me still it's
[__] up because people don't even go
to I went to Best Buy the other day in
this CD section Best Buy is so yeah man
but they said they have a bunch there
used to be like a hip-hop section and
now it's just like one section Best Buy
on my 14th birthday and found Wonderland
by Kelis which was only released in the
UK so they even had Imports coming there
now I used to work at Best Buy we used
to get some like fly like Indie [__]
just so much I just used to be lost in
the music section and now it's like a
small section I missed Tower Records a
bunch of gift cards and washer and dryer